the three things that I want to leave
with you just these three I could do ten
I could do a whole life class
but just these three things
will carry you if you let them
first and foremost
knowing who you are
being able to answer this question
who am I
and what do I want
you know many times when I go out of the
country I am baffled by that question
to explain what is your occupation I've
I've stood there for 10 minutes well am
I talk shows well I'm more than a talk
show host and my businesswoman I'm
business woman I'm more than a
businesswoman and my entrepreneur I'm
more an entrepreneur so I just leave it
blank or self-employed so I'm not asking
for the roles that you play as daughters
I'm not asking
that question what are the roles that
you play as a daughter as a friend as a
sister you're going to be a lawyer
you're going to teach you're going to be
a pharmacist
I'm asking the bigger question of who Am
I who am I really
my answer is I am God's child I am that
which is born of all that is
I am as Peter Chardon said a spiritual
being having a human experience
come trailing the breath of the
ancestors yet but trailing the breath of
the angels and understanding that
because I am connected to the source of
all that is
all that is possible is possible for me
that's who I am
and what do I want
I don't want to just be successful in
the world
I don't want to just
make a Mark or have a legacy
the answer to that question for me is I
want to fulfill the highest truest
expression
of myself as a human being
she can't fix everything and you can't
save every soul but what can you do here
and now I believe you have to declare
war on one of our most dangerous enemies
and that is cynicism because when that
little creature sinks in its hooks into
you it'll Cloud your Clarity it'll
compromise your integrity it'll lower
your standards it'll choke your empathy
and sooner or later
cynicism shatters your faith
when you hear yourself saying oh it
doesn't matter what one person says oh
well so what it's not going to make any
difference what I do who cares when you
hear yourself saying that know that
you're on a collision course for our
culture
and I understand how it's so easy to
become disillusioned so tempting to
allow apathy to set in because anxiety
is being broadcast on 157 channels 24
hours a day all night long
you must have some kind of vision for
your life
even if you don't know the plan you have
to have a direction in which you choose
to go
I never was the kind of woman who liked
to get in a car and just go for a ride
I had a boyfriend would say let's just
go for a ride
I want to know where are we going
do we have a destination
is there a plan are we just riding
what I've learned is that's a great
metaphor for life
you want to be in the driver's seat of
your own life because if you're not life
will drive you
knowing who you really are
in this space and time that we embody
[Music]
that's number one what do you want
who are you do not equate money and fame
with accomplishment and character
because I can assure you based on the
thousands of people I've interviewed one
does not automatically follow the other
something else something else you need
to know this your job is not always
going to fulfill you there will be some
days that you just might be bored
other days you may not feel like going
to work at all
go anyway
and remember that your job is not who
you are it's just what you're doing on
the way to who you will become every
remedial chore every boss who takes
credit for your ideas that is going to
happen
look for the lessons because the lessons
are always there and the number one
lesson I could offer you where your work
is concerned is this become so skilled
so Vigilant so flat out fantastic at
what you do that your talent cannot be
dismissed number two
you must find a way to serve
Martin Luther King said that not
everybody can be famous but everybody
can be great because greatness is
determined by service
now we live in a world where everybody
wants to be famous
and where we admire people for just
being famous
we think being known brings us value
the truth is all of that will fade in
time
the real truth is that
service and the significance that you
bring to your service is that which is
lasting
so to be able to whatever your
occupation or job or Talent OR gift is
our honorees today getting Doctorate
Degrees
is service using the spoken word in
service to community in the world
using your knowledge in service to the
world and if you look at all the most
successful people in the world whether
they know it or not they have that
Paradigm of service
everybody's talking about Mark
Zuckerberg and IPO
service
Jay-Z rapid
service through the word two people
through song
and everybody I know is feeling it
these times
these times are here to let us know that
we need to take a stand for our right to
have hope and we need to take a stand
with every ounce of wit and courage we
can muster the question is what are you
willing to stand for and here's how you
answer it
your honor where your mouth is
put your honor where your mouth is when
you give your word
get your hands dirty and then you'll
begin to draw strength from the
understanding the true knowing that
history is still being written
you're writing it every day
The Wills still in spin and what you do
or what you don't do will be a part of
it
you build a legacy not from one thing
but from everything
stop comparing yourself to other people
you're only on this planet to be you not
someone else's imitation of you I had to
learn that the hard way on the air live
anchoring the news
when I first started Broadcasting
I was 19 and I was just pretending to be
Barbara Walker Walters I was just trying
to talk like Barbara act like Barbara
hold my legs like Barbara
um and I was on the air and I hadn't
read the copy fully and I called Canada
Kanata I did that on the air I cracked
myself up because I thought Barbara
would never call Canada Kanata and that
little breakthrough that little crack
that little moment that I stopped
pretending allowed the real me to come
through
your life journey is about learning to
become more of who you are in fulfilling
the highest truest expression of
yourself as a human being that's why
you're here you will do that through
your work and your art through your
relationships and your love and to quote
Albert Einstein education is what
remains after we forget what we're
taught number three it's so simple but
so hard to do
always do the right thing people notice
think of how you notice you go to Taco
Bell somebody gives you extra napkin and
some sauce
you notice Excellence shows itself be
excellent let Excellence be your brand
everybody talks about building a brand I
never even knew what that was
when people say you're a brand I would
say no I'm just Oprah what I recognize
now is that my choice
to it every way
in every example in every experience
to do the right thing and the excellent
thing is what has created the brand
my life is fueled by my being and the
being fuels the doing
so I come from a centered place I come
from a focused place I come from
compassion it's just my nature I come
from a willingness to understand and to
be understood and I come from wanting to
to connect I mean the secret of that
show for 25 years is that people could
see themselves in me all over the world
they could see themselves in me and even
as I became more and more financially
successful which was a big surprise to
me through the whole process because I'm
grounded in my own self
that although I could have more shoes my
feet stayed on the ground although I was
wearing better shoes he's kind of cute
today too so I could keep my feet on the
ground even though I could get more
shoes and I could understand I could
understand that it really was because I
was grounded I've done the was doing and
continue to this day to do the
Consciousness work I work at staying
awake and being awakened is just another
word for spirituality